hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
today we're checking out the trailer for
5 nights at freddy's part 4 the goal
today to not get scared from a jump
scare okay
that's the goal I'm gonna shut down my
mobile your nerves
[Music]
[Music]
what can you think
[Music]
whatever you pronto
[Music]
yours huh check the closet ah
[Music]
who know
[Music]
I really get scared that's fun that was
fun
yeah the so is this five minutes of
phrase take place in a home yeah I guess
yeah I guess it's like you shot you you
you summoned costume characters home you
know after you when you left for your
shift
oh wow wow game stars over the thing
about five nights at Freddy's is it's
such a cheesy game it's cheesy it's
silly
and yet it's it's really not much
thought put into the game but no it's
just simple it's very simple blast I
don't think it was the lack of thought I
think it's just like a really simple
idea
it is very that's fair that's a much
better way to put it I agree with those
statements whatever he said those are my
words now two at the same time it's
really fun yeah I know I'm really fun
it's a simple thing that's easy to get
absorbed in and you know it's a
jump-scare game yeah you're yeah to let
Henry I played every one of them that's
been out so far and but I've never
actually um beaten like the entire game
I just played like a little bit here a
little bit there so I don't know if
there's like this huge [ __ ] storyline
going with it what people keep freaking
out over it I mean I'm sort of curious
as to how long how many of these don't
make because it makes me think I think
of like Angry Birds you know like how
Angry Birds was just like app game that
got so [ __ ] popular this is like a PC
game that got so [ __ ] popular I feel
like they're gonna keep dishes they're
dishing these out fast so the more they
dish out and this time frame they have
of being popular the more money they're
gonna make oh yeah I mean they're they
should keep going they're clever they
are clever they're smart they're they're
riding that train as far as it'll go
oh it's called momentum in business you
know you got a ride that momentum and as
many sales as much as possible we should
just start a video game company we
should start a business teaching class
that's what we should do and that's what
we're at you do
anyway guys thanks for tuning in and if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out reasons to Gerry and
dank ass Stubbs on the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter by periscope John Matthews woo
oh wow
his parents must be Christian a shout
out would be cool my name is John him
9595 John Matthews on the shout out page
it says you have to say something
interesting in order to earn a shout-out
you have provided nothing of the sort
for us to do a proper shout out I mean
your name's John m95 I mean what's a
John and can i really make fun of that I
mean what is that like it's up a hot dog
the type of penis was John a 95 maybe
when you put your penis in a girl's
Brundle eyes envy you you put your 95
centimeter penis in a girl's butt hole
and then you take it out and then she
dies because the penis was too big is
that what a John in 95 is I don't know
can't come up with a joke here I think
you've done just fine have I yeah all
right shout out complete